[Music]
my planet arrakis is so beautiful when
the sun is low
rolling over the sands you can see spice
in the air
the outsiders ravage our lands in front
of our eyes
[Applause]
their cruelty to my people is all i've
known
what's to become of our world
[Music]
a boy duncan can i trust you something
yes always you know that i've been
having dreams
about a girl or maracas i don't know
what it means
dreams make good stories but everything
important happens when we're awake
yeah you put on some muscle i didn't no
[Applause]
we are house atreides there is no call
we do not answer
there is no faith that we betray
[Music]
smile gurney i am smiling the emperor
asks us to bring peace to arrakis house
atreides
accepts
[Music]
i know you there's something awakening
in my mind
you need to face your fears
come with me
you need to be ready you've never met
harkins before they're not human they're
brutal
the duke's son sees too much
this is why you kill them all
god in heaven
get everything with guns off the ground
go
this is an extermination
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight like demons
dad what if i'm not the future of house
of treaties
a great man doesn't seek to lead he's
called to it
but if your answer is no
you'll still be the only thing i ever
needed you to be
my son
[Applause]
if anything happens
will you protect paul with my life
only together can we stand a chance
[Applause]
it's time